et je suis noire, musulmane, somali-américaine et originaire du Kenya.
(Applaudissements)
Certains ont dit que j'étais une pionnière :
j'étais la première reine musulmane du bal du lycée,
la première étudiante somalienne à être déléguée à la fac
et la première femme voilée dans de nombreux endroits :
le concours de beauté de Miss Minnesota,
les podiums de Milan et les Fashion Weeks de New-York
et même sur la célèbre couverture du « Vogue UK ».
Comme vous le voyez,
je n'ai pas peur d'être la première, de me démarquer, seule,
de prendre des risques,
car c'est cela, de faire partie d'une minorité.
C'est faire office de vaisseau pour créer le changement
et être une représentation humaine de la puissance de la diversité.
J'utilise ma plateforme pour répandre un important message de reconnaissance.
Cela n'a pas toujours été simple.
Quand je suis arrivée aux États-Unis pour habiter à Saint-Louis au Missouri,
je me souviens avoir demandé à ma mère : « Est-ce vraiment l'Amérique ? »
Des choses m'étaient malheureusement familières comme,
entendre des coups de feu la nuit
ou voir la pauvreté dans les rues.
Mais certaines choses étaient très différentes.
Quand je suis arrivée au CP,
j'ai vu que les enfants jouaient en groupes.
En Amérique, ce sont des « cliques ».
De là où je venais, on jouait tous ensemble.
Le genre n'importait pas
et, bien sûr, la race n'importait jamais.
Je me demandais :
« Pourquoi ne comprennent-ils pas le swahili ?
Le swahili est la langue qui rapproche les gens. »
Pour empirer les choses,
mon école n'avait pas de programme d'immersion linguistique en anglais.
Je me levais donc chaque jour,
j'allais à l'école, m'asseyais à mon bureau
et n'apprenais jamais rien.
C'est là que j'ai commencé à perdre espoir,
et tout ce que je voulais, c'était rentrer à Kakuma,
un camp de réfugiés.
Ma mère apprit bientôt que bon nombre de Somaliens
vivaient dans une petite ville du Minnesota.
J'ai donc déménagé au Minnesota à huit ans.
Ma vie a changé quand j'ai rencontré des enfants qui parlaient le somalien,
étudié dans une école avec un programme d'immersion linguistique
et trouvé des professeurs qui se surpassaient,
restant après les cours et pendant la pause déjeuner.
Ils étaient déterminés à m'aider à réussir en classe.
Être une enfant réfugiée m’a appris qu’il était possible de manquer de tout :
de nourriture, d’un abri, d’eau potable,
même d’amitié.
Mais la seule chose qu’on ne pourra jamais vous enlever,
c’est votre éducation.
J’ai donc fait des études ma priorité
et j’ai commencé à m’épanouir au sein de la classe.
En grandissant, je suis devenue plus consciente des autres
et de leurs vues sur mon ethnie et mes origines.
Surtout quand j’ai commencé à porter un foulard sur la tête, le hijab.
Lorsque j’ai commencé à le porter, j’étais enchantée.
J’admirais celui de ma mère et je voulais égaler sa beauté.
Mais quand j’ai commencé le collège,
les élèves me taquinaient de ne pas avoir de cheveux.
Alors, pour leur donner tort,
j’ai commencé à leur montrer mes cheveux,
un acte contre mes croyances, mais je me suis forcée à le faire.
À l’époque, je voulais tellement m’intégrer.
Quand je pense aux problèmes d’ethnicité, de religion et d’identité,
beaucoup de mauvais souvenirs ressurgissent.
Il me serait aisé de blâmer les personnes issues d’une autre culture
pour la souffrance que je ressentais.
Mais en y réfléchissant plus,
j’admets aussi que les événements les plus percutants,
les plus positifs et les plus bouleversants de ma vie
me sont arrivés grâce aux personnes différentes de moi.
C’est à ce moment que j’ai décidé de quitter ma zone de confort
et de participer à un concours, avec un hijab et un burkini.
Ce fut une opportunité d’être une voix pour les femmes
qui, comme moi, se sentaient sous-représentées.
Même si je n’ai pas gagné le concours,
cette expérience m’a ouvert tellement de portes.
Je recevais des e-mails et des messages de femmes du monde entier.
Elles disaient que je les inspirais car je restais juste fidèle à moi-même.
Il y a eu d’autres « premières fois ».
L’icône de la mode Carine Roitfeld m’a conviée à New York
pour photographier mon tout premier éditorial.
C’est à cette période que je suis devenue le premier mannequin voilé
et, lors de la première année,
j’ai fait la couverture de neuf magazines de mode.
On pouvait dire que j'étais extrêmement occupée.
Même avec ce succès soudain,
une chose demeurait :
l'idée que tout cela finirait par me ramener à Kakuma,
mon chez moi.
Il y a quelques mois, il m'est arrivé quelque chose d'incroyable.
J'étais à New York pour une séance photo,
lorsque j'ai rencontré Adut Akech, un mannequin du Soudan du Sud
qui est elle aussi née à Kakuma.
Cette expérience en elle-même est la définition de l'espoir.
Imaginez juste cela :
deux jeunes filles nées dans le même camp de réfugiés,
réunies pour la première fois pour faire la couverture du « Vogue UK ».
(Applaudissements)
J'ai eu le plaisir de travailler en coopération avec l'UNICEF,
car je connaissais déjà leur travail pour les enfants dans le besoin.
N'oubliez surtout pas
que bien que les enfants d'ici soient des réfugiés,
ils restent des enfants.
Ils méritent de s'épanouir, d'espérer, de rêver...
et de réussir.
Mon histoire a commencé ici, dans le camp de réfugiés de Kakuma,
un endroit plein d'espoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)